Problem with his papers is craigslist.
This guy named Craig sets up a mailing
list and craigslist.org.
It's the ugliest site you've ever seen.
And if you want to get a couch unloaded,
that's where you go instead of the
classifieds.
Now the idea that somehow we owe it to
newspapers in order to get decent
reportage and have a New York Times
Baghdad bureau to subsidize them by not
allowing craigslist to exist so that we
still have to go through them to place
our classifieds.
Ridiculous enough notion that it's no
doubt a straw man and nobody would ever
say such a thing.
Um,
so newspapers do have a problem in that
what they have to offer and what many of
us think is a good thing that they do,
unbiased reporting and professional
journalism seems to be a substitutable
product with cats,
flushing toilets on youtube.
And so long as that's the case and
people are like,
hmm,
news about a rock kept flushing toilet,
I'd watch either of them.
So long as the cat flushing the toilet
is cheaper,
that's going to have more supply and
that's where the demand will go.
So what we're really complaining about
is the fact that there's some ethos and
profession of journalism that has been
subject to high pressure market forces
that are driving it out.
To me,
the real solution there,
if we think the news is valuable and
there isn't the market framework to
support it,
you subsidize it.
It's how you get NPR.
It's how you get pbs because you think
yet another channel of I dream of
Jeannie reruns,
even though that's pound for pound,
what earns more money for the channel
operator?
Then Pvs,
we'd rather have pbs in the mix too,
and we're prepared to see what we can do
to make it happen.